salut pour ce nouveau master class on va
parler encore du palais de mémoire au
mois de mars dernier dans la vidéo
numéro 65 je vous parlais du palais
mental je vous présentais ça avec toutes
les techniques de mémoire qu'on avait
appris au préalable vous pouviez
associer l'ensemble dans un palais
mental un peu à la charge si vous n'avez
pas vu cette vidéo je vous invite à la
regarder tout de suite parce que ce
master class est la suite logique du
palais mental au final vous l'avez
compris il faut de l'ordre de
l'association et de la répétition
l'ordre c'est ce que vous avez dû faire
depuis le mois de mars en temps normal
peut-être à partir d'aujourd'hui vous
allez devoir vous entraîner un peu
différemment à chaque fois que vous
balader dans votre palais mental ou pas
rater du départ pour aller jusqu'à
l'arrivée ce qui serait intéressant
maintenant c'est que vous vous
entraîniez dans des ordres différents
c'est à dire vous propulser dans
n'importe quelle pièce où donc n'importe
quel endroit doit de palets ou de
commencer par la fin pour remonter au
début pour le maîtriser un peu sous
toutes les formes sous toutes les
coutures pour passer une étape
maintenant dans vos associations il va
falloir vous forcez absolument à jouer
sur l'émotion l'émotion dans la mémoire
c'est soit quelque chose qui surprend
quelque chose qui peut faire rire
quelque chose de complètement atypique
de complètement hors propos quelque
chose qui fait peur pourquoi pas c'est
tout ce qui n'est pas logique tout ce
qui va susciter un regard différent de
votre part être votre conscience si je
devais associer un objet courant comme
un stylo à un crochet de mémoire qui
serait une main je peux pas retenir que
le crayon et dans la main ça n'a aucun
intérêt en fait en termes d'émotion par
contre si je commence à me transpercé la
main avec le stylo mentalement ou même
faire de l'acupuncture avec 1,2 kg sur
le dos de la main alors là ça crée une
émotion en l'occurrence la douleur et
c'est certain que je vais le retenir
beaucoup plus efficacement vos images
doivent est extraordinaire vous devez
travailler dans ce sens là et elle vous
viendront toujours plus facilement
toujours plus spontanément et la
révolution c'est un petit peu comme
l'ordre une fois que vous avez fournée
votre palais mentale d'information
continue à vous balader et d'aller voir
ces informations d' aller les voir
régulièrement pas forcément dans le même
ordre en fait pour bien les fixer dans
son esprit il faut continuer à se
balader de temps en temps et c'est ça
qui est formidable c'est que à chaque
temps faibles de la journée vous n'avez
besoin de rien d'autre que de votre
esprit pour pouvoir le faire
la manière la plus classique je vous
l'avais dit dans la vidéo 65 d'utiliser
le palais mental c'est pour retenir des
listes de choses des listes d'objets
mais on peut retenir des cours entier on
peut retenir des discours entière on
peut retenir des réunions de travail
entière si on associe le palais mental
avec le my maps avec la carte mentale
dont je vous parlais dans la vidéo
réussi à ses examens puisque la vraie
clé de mémorisation c'est la
compréhension
donc la carte mentale va vous permettre
de synthétiser des choses de les
comprendre globalement complètement et
de pouvoir faire un schéma
synthétique dans votre esprit c'est la
première bulle de votre carte mentale
que vous allez pouvoir associer à votre
palais mentale ce qui fait qu en vous
baladant dans votre palais mental quand
vous allez tomber sur cette bulle là
vous allez avoir toute la carte mentale
tu va vous revenir un petit peu comme
une explosion et là ça devient puissant
de ouf cette méthode est très efficace
avait pas nouvelle elle a quasiment
trois mille ans un petit peu moins les
sénateurs romains s'en servaient pour un
discours les grecs avaient trouvé ça
l'histoire raconte on se passe il ya les
vrais que c'est simonide de six ans qui
a trouvé cette idée pour mémoriser
simonide était un poète grec c'était un
des rares pour être peut-être même le
seul à être rémunéré d'après les écrits
de cicéron c'est lui qui aurait inventé
la méthode des lieux qui est la base du
palais mental un jour ce copain ce qui
était un tyran commande un poème à
simonide si maudite écrit le poème
l'écrit aussi bien qu'il le peut le
livre ascopa ce qui dit tu seras pas
payer tu seras payé que la moitié parce
que dans ton poème un moment donné tu
parles trop de castor et pollux alors
que le poème devais m dédiés donc je te
paie la moitié l'autre moitié tu l'as
demandera aux dieux et là dessus il
invite à manger sûrement pour réciter le
poème à un moment donné l'heure du repas
simoni d'état pris à l'extérieur où il
ya deux personnes qui l'attendent
il doit absolument aller à l'extérieur
donc il se libère de la table il va
dehors et au moment où il va dehors le
palais s'effondre sur tous les invités
et si monique comprend que les deux
personnes qui l'attendaient dehors son
castor et pollux dont il avait écrit sur
la moitié du poème leurs louanges le
problème au delà que c'est une hécatombe
sous le palais c'est comme le palais
s'est effondré les familles ne savent
pas où chercher les corps ne savent même
pas des fois les reconnaître charge des
objets des gens précis et c'est là que
simonide dit mais moi je sais où et tout
mais moi je sais qui et qui je sais où
les choses sont placés puisque j'étais
assis j'ai juste à fermer les yeux et à
me remémorer et tout va me revenir aux
faits à mesure et c'est comme ça qu'ils
ont retrouvé les corps etc simonide
pouvait donner l'identité de toutes les
personnes c'est de là que serait née
l'idée en tout cas de la méthode des
lieux et du palais mental j'espère que
ce nouveau master class sur le sujet
vous aura plu je vais commencer à faire
des suites de ce qui a été fait par
exemple la semaine prochaine je vous
dise un peu le prochain masters classes
ce sera la suite sur le col reading et
ça je sais que ça vous intéresse cette
vidéo est sorti un petit peu à la bourre
aujourd'hui encore à mal le samedi c'est
à 11h aujourd'hui elle va sortir
sûrement vers 11h40 midi parce qu'il est
exactement 11 heures j'ai eu un problème
avec ma carte sd et comme j'ai pas de
matériel d' avance mais je le note un
grand merci spécial à tous ceux qui font
les sous titres des vidéos c'est vrai
que je parle pas souvent de vous il ya
ludivine ya plein d'autres personnes pas
il ya plein de personnes n'en vous êtes
assez peu non
nombreux à le faire mais vous en faites
beaucoup donc merci beaucoup plus ça
ouvre toutes les vidéos aux
malentendants et ça c'est grâce à vous
et je fais ça
si vous voulez que cette vidéo
atteignent les étoiles n'oubliez pas de
mettre un pouce qui vise lui vers la
lune vous pouvez également laisser un
commentaire au bas de la vidéo vous
abonner à la chaîne parce que le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an donc rendez vous de demain à 11
heures
ciao
oui